yeah so our second speaker is Gregory
Zeidler who's also at IBM research
Europe Zurich and yeah so he will talk
about the the actual constructions that
actually how to construct that was
multiplicative and unstructured proves
that I mentioned in the previous talk so
thank you thanks for the introduction
yes yeah we know this is about basically
techniques we have developed in maybe
the last six months or so and in
particular this is joint work with
Thomas Mohammed Vadim and calm and yeah
so maybe I should also say so you have
already said a lot of things that I need
but this talk is still going to be
somewhat self-contained so I will
basically reiterate some of the things
and I hope this is useful because there
will be slightly different notation
interval someone introduced a slightly
different point of view and then it's
good to have this in mind for the later
talk later part of the talk okay so
let's yeah so let me just start very
lightly and some set the stage again and
what we're interested in so basically
what we tried to do or what we're trying
to do is build the knowledge of truths
as they are needed for ledger space
constructions practical skills and maybe
the most important practical schemes
which really have the amount of proofs
at their core may be privacy preserving
protocols and one particular example of
this is group signatures and if one
builds these schemes the lattice
problems then basically the thing one
has to prove always is of the form of
this equation on the slide so you really
have to just prove a linear equation
over six you
which as well the solution is short it
is very important otherwise of course
the problem wouldn't be very interesting
and short for this talk always means
that the coefficients of s they are is
the demon said they have basically
ternary so and then minus 1 0 & 1 okay
so so if if we are looking at let us
play the schemes then of course it is
somewhat natural to also try to build
the knowledge proofs that that we need
with lattice techniques so this is maybe
elegant but it also has practical
advantages namely it leads to simple
implementations if you don't have
something which is completely different
so the proof system will basically be
able to reuse most of the computational
things that are also needed for the
underlying schemes schemes and maybe
from a more theoretical point of view
it's also interesting because we we
won't introduce any any new hardness
assumptions but as Medina's also said
there are actually very efficient PCP
types somewhat generic proof systems
with security only really rests on on
the security of hash function f
functions so ii ii points doesn't really
apply to them and yeah so in practice
this means if it turns out that these
pcp type systems are maybe a factor of
10 or affect or maybe even two orders of
magnitude more efficient than what we
can lattices then it gets really hard to
argue why we're not using them so this
we always have to keep in mind and if
you someone dig a bit look at this a bit
more closer then it turns out that they
are basically a good and a bad answer in
today's in the bed answer I want to
start first with so the bad answer is
that we don't really have efficient look
a rhythmic lattice based proof systems
inside so look a rhythmic he means that
the proof size is look
with make in say the business eyes in
case of our equation basically the
length of the vector if you want to
prove and but the good thing is and this
is really basically knew that there has
been a lot of progress on efficient
linear proof systems in the last months
or in the last year and even so much
progress that we can actually beat PCP
type through systems now for statement
sizes that we encounter in in actually
yeah interesting cryptographic
constructions based on lattice
assumptions okay so my team has given PI
examples I let me just read repeat them
so what we are not able to do is we we
can prove knowledge of website to do bit
integer in yeah so what do you say it's
something like seven kilobytes I think
it's more like maybe five point six
kilobytes and for the these equations
that we need for for lattice for
underlying lattice five schemes we can
prove knowledge of a solution of
basically say 2048 unknowns what you
were prime which is 32-bit large in in
less than 50 kilowatts so this is
literally basically the problem s13 has
said that that you need to solve if you
want to prove an Arab Lisa so basically
the tech wait message here is that there
is a regime of problems where linear
systems can be interesting and yeah we
also yeah I think was like this but just
let me repeat this it's also not just
important to to somewhat compare proof
science but what is also of course
interesting in practice is is the ranch
on was these algorithms and it turns out
that will let us say systems we are
basically if I had in in run time then
what can we do what can be done with
these generic construction so even if
our constructions are maybe slightly
worse in terms of proof size then we
will still be able to beat PCP type
systems based on run time
so maybe to make this a bit more
concrete and they have been papers which
have studied how to basically solve
these linear equations over ZQ with for
example Aurora and somewhere yeah they
basically found that the the ranch ends
of the prove of these implementations
they in the order of several tens of
seconds and we are pretty sure that the
lattices although we don't really have
an implementation for exactly these
problems but somewhere extrapolating
from from signature schemes and in
different schemes if it's pretty clear
that one can implement our proof systems
in with runtimes which are in the order
of maybe a few milliseconds or even less
so there's really a large gap okay yeah
I think that bonnie and others but do
they construct a lot of space snark
right so you know in principle this
should be easy but I thought their goal
was concrete efficiency if you know how
how would you know do you know how this
how it compares to you know the
efficiency goal that you want so I'm not
aware of that they have really concrete
numbers like in in size of kilobytes so
and it would be surprised if this is if
if their results are really small like
tens of kilobyte but so yeah so
basically yeah so our goal is to
construct proof systems for which which
are linear and but which concretely have
have small true sizes and if one
basically accepts its that the system
will be linear then the next big problem
the front faces is soundness and the
reason basically is that yeah in these
proof systems there will always be some
challenges from the verifier and yeah
basically all the problems we have
they're really easy to solve if we allow
for challenges which come from the queue
so this would result in a sum of 1 over
Q because usually by guessing the
challenge you can cheat so if there's
only Q elements or only cure challenges
then the probability one of a coupon
that doesn't have the secret will still
succeed and somehow this is kind of in
condor basically contrary to the yeah
what is nice about let us cryptography
or the high speed we see in lattice
cryptography because one reason for the
high speed in lattice cryptography
actually is that we usually work with a
small Q so for example in the case of
cables or some encryption system that
was submitted to missed their queue
really is just basically two to the
twelfth watch and in our proof system so
basically for our proof system serves
for proving some underlying scheme so if
you want to prove something in this case
about Kaiba then we kind of are forced
to also take take the same queue so this
would basically if he would stew
everything naively as is basically known
how to do it then it would result in a
scheme which needs to be repeated and
basically ten times to get media to post
on this error and it turns out that such
a scheme wouldn't be really competitive
anymore in terms of full size so
Medina's already said that signature
schemes get around this problem by
introducing polynomial challenges so
they work with a sum ring Internet the
challenges which come from a polynomial
but as my team has already explained and
I will say this again quickly this is
not so easy for proving things about
committing scripts so therefore some of
the techniques I'm going to introduce
they're basically aiming at constructing
protocols that achieve negligible
soundness error without being basically
simple repetitions or some base protocol
with
a big summer Sara so this is only to
keep in mind and this is at least in my
view this is somewhat the biggest
problem one has if I'm wants to
construct really efficient practical
better space keeps lettuce tastes yeah
systems okay so with this introduction I
now start with some techniques and
basically the first thing we have to
agree with basically the Rings with
arithmetic and for this talk I'm
choosing such a power of two cycle try
drinking it Vadim has already introduced
and in our case it actually turns out
that choosing in fixed small cyclotomic
like that one given on the slides of
rank 128 turns out to be basically
always in us because you get yeah
basically a scheme which I have secured
which parameter 1 and 28 so sum is 2 to
the minus 1/9 28 okay so yeah this is
kind of already done by a team again but
I use slightly different notation so I
say again what the commitment scheme is
that we are working with and maybe
explain this admits more in details out
in in a proof system this is usually
works that you commit to the secret that
you know so in our case this is some
vector that fulfills some some linear
equation and then in order to prove
these these product and unstructured
linear relations that we are aiming at
you need to have a commitment scheme
which is kind of sort of malleable so
that in the end by applying for example
said no more physics you get something
which is zero and then you prove that
your message is zero and by that you pre
you prove some some linear relations so
I will explain this now so that's just
just
let me recall the commitment scheme so
in this commitment scheme that we are
using there's some some public matrix B
0 and then there are a couple of vectors
B 1 B 2 and so on and now you can
actually commit to arbitrary polynomials
from our ring and you do this by
sampling some short random vector R then
you compute p0 times R so this resulting
t0 and this is basically for committing
to the randomness and then for
committing to the messages you compute
scalar products of these vectors VI with
the randomness vector plus the messages
and I will maybe slightly sloppily then
say that for example t1 is a commitment
to m1 although of course you also need
these two zeros of it the whole thing
really is a commitment yeah and yeah as
we have seen before so this thing is
hiding and binding and the hiding comes
from the fact that basically in every of
these polynomials there's an some
independent module ìwe sample and the
thing is fighting because if you would
be able to come up with a different
opening with a different message then
you would also need to change the
randomness vector and this will would
lead to a one Yosi solution for B 0 so
in the first equation so and what's
basically other than the kind of
operations we can we can perform so
there's basically we can do any we can
apply any module homomorphism over a
cube so if we are given these two
commitments t1 and t2 from the previous
slide what we can do is we can just
linear combine them with two polynomials
a 1 and a 2 from our queue and then if
we just plug in these expressions for t1
and t2 from the previous slide just by
by some algebra what we get is this
exactly of the form of a new commitment
so there's some some new vector or
matrix P 3 which is just the linear
combination of P 1 and P 2 and
the message part is it's really
basically what we're interested in then
with a linear combination of of a M 1
and M 2 and this is useful because if we
now have a tool to prove that T 3
actually is a commitment to 0 then this
applies in linear relation so in this
case shape times M 1 plus a 2 times M 2
equals 0
some question no ok so now we have our
commitment scheme and so I said what we
need to basically be able to do is prove
linear relations on the messages and
this first implies that we need to be
able to to prove knowledge off of an
opening for the commitment or I mean of
course it doesn't make sense that we
also need to prove that claim with some
commitment is really really well formed
and that we actually committed to
something and this works by yeah giving
this approximate proof of the first
equation that the team has already
explained so yeah this is just a
standard Sigma protocol which is moral
to ask - no proofs I'm not going into
details here just maybe to - to give the
notation so this masking vector Y which
is central at the beginning this yeah
I'll write this as vector Y and then the
challenge comes from some distribution
big C and in the end the true percent
some vector set which is y plus ya and
now to s this proved to - that the
message is 0 or we need to is that the
prover also has to compute leave 3y and
the verifier has to check some more
equation and yeah so this is also
important that this additional
polynomial X doesn't have to be sent in
the non inductive part because we've can
then detect as basically inputs to the
hash function which is used for the
challenge polynomial so the in practice
this means proving
Linnea relation over or our in our queue
is as cheap as just proving knowledge of
an opening to off the commitment and no
matter how many basically relations we
prove which is very useful okay so in
the opening proof what we get is not
really what we might want to get so we
don't really prove a pre-image of t0 but
of basically t0 times some small
polynomial C by the reason is is reading
as explained that in the in the
extraction we try to get to accepting
transcripts and we call the the
difference of the two challenges Z bar
and week in then basically it
subtracting the the verification
equation we get the equation which is
written there and it doesn't really make
sense to divide by Z bar because
dividing by some small polynomial will
lead in something big which is not
really interesting for this equation so
all we do proof is that we know a short
preimage to t 0 and of course i mean the
owners proven oysters you can just
multiply his r by z bar but what what we
can extract from the proof is actually
much longer than but what the owners
proven oats this is why this proof is
called approximate now for signatures
this is enough and all we need to do but
now I come to the path by polynomial
challenges alone in in in zero knowledge
proof social commitment I'm not really
enough and and epidemis already said
this is this problem with the
invertibility of LC bar so kind of
intuitively the reason is that we also
have to multiply all the other equations
so all the all the polynomials that
actually commit to something by C bar
and then we don't really end up proving
that the message we're interested in
interested in is zero but we prove that
the message times C bar is zero and this
is only really
if c ba is invertible otherwise yeah we
don't know and we look at this a bit
more detail so recall that the ring we
work with so the signal Tomic of Rank 1
and 28
this is splits into into a product of
smaller fields and for this talk I'm
basically assuming that Q and some prime
in say the order of 2 to the 32 and it
is such that the ring actually splits
completely so this means that what you
look you today is 256 primitive root of
unity and then the the factors of this
you would use a polynomial X and X to
the 1 and 28 plus 1 over C yeah these
are these linear factors X minus I where
I all the 256 root of unity yeah if I go
back to this equation so if C bar is not
invertible this essentially means that
in one of these factors and let's call
them yeah basically the entity factors
are basically one of the entity
coefficients of C bar will be zero
because otherwise if C bar would have
entity coefficients which are all
nonzero then C bar would be invertible
and the equation of basswood
would make what would give what we want
but if C bar is zero in one of them
basically entity slots then there we
don't learn anything because we might
apply something that we want to prove by
zero and then of course this is
trivially seeds of zero okay so what can
be done about this I mean the usual
strategy that has been used before is to
just choose that the set the challenges
comes from in such a way that just every
difference of two elements is invertible
and then we just we don't don't have
this problem because we know that C bar
is invertible and they're left in
several some our techniques apply
so I explained in the literature in the
demon sense more detail how one can
construct such sets but basically this
always has in common that there cannot
be large challenge set unless q doesn't
really split much and one can also very
easily see this from counting argument
so if you assume that as we do our ring
splits completely then all these fields
the entity coefficients live in they are
just two Q large so their size is just Q
so if you have a challenge set which is
bigger than Q then there must be
collision so there is a is a difference
of two challenge which is zero in this
entity slot so it's clear that such sex
cannot exist in our case and what we now
do it differently
is that we basically observe that
non-invertible Seba are not useless so
what he doesn't really explain this so
let me spend a bit more time on this so
if we look at this equation before then
yeah it is not completely useless
because it actually does prove the
relation we are interested in all the
where C bar is nonzero so one possible
strategy can be that we just somehow try
to set up our proof in such a way that
you can get many transcripts pair
transcript pairs with many different
differences of the challenges such that
model every of these degree one
polynomial X minus RJ one of the C bar
chase so completely so we really want to
have as many transfer pairs in the
extraction as we have entity
coefficients and then basically the J's
C bar is non 0 modulo X to the minus R X
minus object and
yeah so if then we basically can piece
together all our extraction and they
give what we want because from from each
from the Jade extraction we learned that
the relation we are interested in holds
modulo the je degree one polynomial and
all together they prove what we want
okay so this could already lead to some
some solution to our problem but we need
one more ingredient for for basically to
make this really efficient and for this
we have to look at the translating or
the splitting of a ring in a bit more
detail and what we see is that or what
especially well known is that this ring
doesn't immediately split into these
linear Rank 1 factors but it actually
splits recursively in rings modulo
polynomials which are of a very nice
form so which are all monomials and in
particular basically it splits into some
some polynomial of degree 4 yeah all
right Tommy polynomials fit into some
pretty knowledge degree 4 which also is
is binomial sum which is of the form X
to the 4 minus in this case are 1 to the
4 and this is also really at the heart
of why entity evidence are so fast
because you have this divide and
conquer' way of of splitting or rings
successively into more and more factors
until you reach the entity coefficients
plus we now need also some some autumn
or physics for a ring and it turns out
that our ring our q actually has group
of automorphisms which we might call out
odds of like you and these automatisms
they act very nicely on on these factors
of a cube and in particular by this I
mean that there is some cyclic subgroup
and let's say this subgroup is generated
by some automorphism
Sigma but stabilizes every of these rank
4 yeah basically sub drinks and in
addition rotates the effect of dividing
it so to explain this a bit more clearly
I have some some graphics here so let's
assume we start with some polynomial C
so in the end we will be interested in
challenges this why I call this C and
then if we look at the image of see in
these in the in this rank foreing that
we basically encountered before going
all the way down to the to the entity
factors then there we basically get C
mod X to the 4 minus 1 to the 4 and then
if you go all the way down we we get the
entity coefficients of C and let's call
them C head 1 to see it fall so that the
ones which lie under X to the 4 minus 1
to the 4 and if you now apply or
automorphism so this that generates yeah
the cyclic subgroup which I say it acts
nicely so first I didn't really apply it
I just wrote Sigma 0 so that I still
have the same as before but now if I
apply Sigma once then what you see is
that in the tops here now if the
polynomial Sigma 1 or C so this is
really just Sigma try to see then in
this rank for ring you of course also
helps then Sigma 1 C mod X to the 4
minus 1 to the 4 and now the interesting
thing is that the entity factors are
basically or the entity coefficients are
the same as before they are just
rejected so before we started with C 1
and then it's 2 3 and 4 now we start
with 4 and if I now apply the Sigma a
couple of more times I see that I
basically just reached rotate these
entity factors this will be very useful
because this allows us to set up our
proof so that in the extraction we can
get challenges Seba which are 1 0 modulo
degree four polynomial so suppose some
word that I'll prove that we will
someone look at in a minute that this
allows for getting in its extraction
where Simba is nonzero much X to the
four - I want to the fall then this of
course means that C bar must be nonzero
in one of the basically rank one vectors
which lie under this rank for factor
because otherwise Sasebo would be 0 in
the indirect for factor and now because
we have these autumn morphisms which
rotate the entity coefficients this
means that actually for every of the
rank one factors there will be one
rotation of C bar which is nonzero in in
this particular for differently so C bar
basically and we start off with assuming
that C bar doesn't have all the four
entity coefficients and in this group of
four nonzero and then by rotating them
we can basically get get a polynomial
which has a nonzero in in in one of
their entity slots off of our choice and
together you have a question
oh wait I have to move this other way
you can read it okay oh but maybe that's
not a bad idea to read out the question
okay sure
well it's fairly technical so the
question about I guess it's about your
the order morphisms you are talking
about is doesn't this hold whenever the
prime splits completely we don't need it
to split tool in ears but just need the
ramification indices to be equal the
Galois group will just permute this
prime I he's probably my deals right
sure yeah I don't really get what the
question is is is heading it um whenever
the prime splits completely yeah this is
basically what I said right
so I mean maybe maybe yeah so the fact
that the primes flipped completely is
precisely watch what I maybe I I
understand what the question is asking
so maybe it doesn't split in this nice
binomial way is this what the question
is asking so but because splitting
completely means that it splits into
prime ideals which has degree 1 which is
exactly the situation I was looking at
yeah I'm asking doing it please just
split it into Linnaeus now this is what
I'm assuming yes yeah this is answered
the question the question was do you
really need it to split completely and I
think the answer is no I mean this this
you can have apply out on Murphy's ins
it doesn't split completely you just
have less so so for example so if he
would not split completely but say in
only ideals prime ideals of 2 3 4 then
basically this group of automorphisms
it's a cyclic group that I was looking
at this will just be some some
automorphism of on this on this field
but it's basically for reasons I'm that
will be useful in this vadim has
explained later for our purposes we do
want a ring to spit completely because
it is useful in later protocols I mean
it doesn't split completely you don't
need the autumn or fizzes you already
have your know your invertibility right
yeah so this is only interesting if it
splits and you don't have right yeah so
the reason is yeah so yeah maybe if ya
explained that what we do need in the
end is that we can extract a C bar so I
challenge difference which is nonzero in
all the basically in all the prime
fields so in although the entity
coefficients if you want to call them
like this and now if our ring doesn't
split completely then all already by
this assumption that I made on the
previous slide that C bar mod X to the 4
minus r1 would would give us the
situation and then having such an
extraction would prove some something
useful modulo this this polynomial but
in our case I do assume that the ring
splits further or the the prime space
further and so we do need extraction
for for all of of the prime ideals so we
do need in the end C bar modulo all of
these linear factors X minus aa and we
achieve this by just assuming we can get
some C bar which is modulo which is non
0 modulo some degree 4 polynomial and
then there will be some of the rotations
which is nonzero in in in the in there
what do you love the linear factors well
basically what you love the primary oh
yeah so I hope this is now it's clear so
from now I cannot close this window okay
yeah so from a protocol point of view
what we now do is just we repeat our
protocol the basic opening protocol for
x and yeah basically the sample for
masking polynomials of masking vectors
YJ where each YJ is there to to to mask
the the random ins times the rotation of
C with Sigma to the J so it's kind of a
repetition all of the previous protocol
but instead of completely independent
challenges we we have one global
challenge and in there in there in the
repetitions then we use the fermentation
or salsa based global charge and yeah
now you might ask why are we doing this
and the reason is basically to fall so
first it turns out that sending these
set set J which maskings of hard times
these rotations of C this is going to be
cheaper than sending basically maskings
with their challenges which are
completely independent this is maybe
there's smaller reason and the really
the big reason is that it turns out that
in the product in linear proofs that I'm
heading it that there this additional
structure that we have for the challenge
allows for four protocols which don't
have to be repeated at all so you might
remember that in the bidding beginning I
say the soundness is really someone the
big problem to get two small concrete
sizes now I was repeating basically some
protocol just four times with four times
the size so you might wonder why I was
saying in the beginning that repetition
is bad but it turns out that we only
this opening proof kind of has to be
repeated four times and all the other
things I'm going to prove because of the
structure I have now I don't have to
repeat and we will see this in detail
later say some more question
yeah this is Chris I had the question in
for the first bullet why is it cheaper
yeah this basically means you you don't
yeah I was teaching a bit here some what
you really will send in the protocol is
not that as I've written there but what
you will basically decompose see in a
write C and over this suffering of rank
4 and then multiplying are with
basically with this coefficient in the
basis of your full ring over this
suffering leads to a smaller basically C
times R and then you just mask these
polynomials and the verifier can then
recombine them to get all the to get all
the basically the the masking she's
interested in with yeah with the
rotations of see
but yeah I haven't really explained it
Thanks so yeah I see what you mean now
yeah okay so now the big question is I
just gave this protocol and I said what
we try to do is we try to be able to get
an extraction for every of these rank or
degree for polynomials which has nonzero
change defense there and how do we do
this is basically what what even said
but maybe now it's more concretely so
the verifier will sample the challenge
polynomial from some ternary
distribution and in such a way that all
the coefficients so let's call them c0
to CE D minus 1 they will be basically
independent sampled from some
distribution of a minus 1 0 1 and then
we see that we can rewrite our
polynomial by just grouping together
yeah coefficients which are basically
four apart
so this basically means is kind of what
I said before we write C in the standard
basis over our rank for suffering and
now by writing C in this form you see
that if I reduce C modulo X to the four
minus say out to the fork then what I do
is just I evaluate these four
polynomials at out to the four to get
the coefficients of the of this
basically degree three polynomial that I
get by reducing modulo this degree four
polynomial and since all these
polynomials they involve disjoint sets
of polynomials of our original see the
is obvious that these coefficients they
will be completely independent so if we
just analyze the distribution of one of
these coefficients and one can for
example prove that slightly informal
because it's of course depends on the
parameters parameters and so on but you
can set parameters in such a way that
the coefficients of C mod X to the four
minus r4 so these relations of the
polynomials
for that they have maximum probability
over the queue which is really close to
1 over Q so yeah essentially they will
be uniform and since I said before our
queue is basically in the order to do
the 32 our coefficient will have maximum
probability which is essentially to do
the minus 32 so why can I get now the
extractions that I want and intuitively
the reason for this is that if some
proof of would want to cheat so he would
never answer they would pick one of only
answer polynomials which have a
particular value what do you know X to
the 4 minus R to the 4 then his success
probability would be basically at most 2
to the minus 1 at 28 because the best
thing he could do is he can sum you
could hope that the polynomial see that
he sees is the one where all the
coefficients have maximum probability
but they all have maximum probability
which is specially 2 to the minus 30
tools so that you get but he gets this
degree 3 polynomial has probability
essentially to do the minus 1 I'm 28 now
of course we need extractions C bar
which are non 0 modulo all these rank
for degree 4 polynomial set appear and
these C's will not be independent
modular the different different degree C
for polynomials but you don't really
need this because we are fine with
having different basically extractions
so what we can do in the rewinding is
and we definitely just want run the
prover until we get the first successful
transcript so first yeah
challenge and then for every year of
these degree fall polynomials really
rewind the prover and send fresh
challenges which just differ what you
know this degree 4 polynomial until we
get basic
successful it which is then different
from the first module of this polynomial
and in this way we can really get one
transcript pair with mon0 challenge
difference module all these degree for
polynomials and this is what we need
then to also have because we always them
have proved a replies of baby for all of
these C bars we have for pro level
replies and there will always be one for
every of the entity factors which is
which is nonzero and then we can piece
everything together to get basically
complete solutions as we wanted okay so
then there's one more thing in the
extraction argument which turns out to
be really nice in later applications so
I'm going to also explain this briefly
now so it actually turns out that
approval which has sufficiently high
success probability so that we can
extract something useful basically
always has to answer or has to send jets
which are a very particular form namely
it is really of this form why basically
be said J in the transcripts a of good
we always of the form YJ plus Sigma J C
times R for basically constant YJ are
that we can extract so yeah maybe [ __ ]
it's a lot of years of what I mean for
maybe yeah so either yes yeah so what
would I have to restrict to here is that
the probe are basically always ends the
same commitment in the first flow which
you can also of course the cheese pipe I
just always just rewinding to just after
the first flow and not just are the Z J
always of this form with constant YJ and
but really the R is the randomness in
the commitments so we then also know
that all these ti commitments they're
really precisely of the form bir plus mr
this turns out to be really useful tool
because it makes writing sounds proofs
for
protocols which are based on this
opening prove much simpler because you
now have these precise expressions for
the prover replies and further for the
commitments and then you can just plug
them in into your verification equations
and don't have to yeah handle the
challenge differences and you don't have
to subtract application equations like
when did previously so it turns out to
be much easier to work with this and
this is also sort of kind of at least in
my view kind of surprising because we
don't stop for a fixed J we don't have a
nonzero challenge well let's put it
differently so they the set J
there's YJ which always masks the same
rotation of C so there's a sigma j c and
for this basically fixed rotation of c
bar we don't have basically a transcript
which is non 0 modulo all the entity
factors and still we can someone
uniquely compute this we J and all the
proven replies always have to be
consistent also with this YJ everywhere
which is kind of surprising and in
practice this gives us a nice additional
tool because we can really use these YJ
to commits to additional messages so in
these proofs there sometimes auxiliary
information that we need to commit to
and it's kind of annoying to need to
increase randomness of the original
commitment scheme just to basically be
able to commit additional messages and
now we can just use these Y J's that we
have anyhow in our opening proof to to
commit to new things which is useful
okay so yeah maybe there's a good point
now to ask if there's any questions
okay so because now I
to really start with the the product and
linear proof that we are eventually
heading it okay so yeah to start with
this our goal now really is to prove
this linear equation a s equals u mod Q
with a ternary vector S and now so we
now have our commitment scheme we keep
we can prove openings about it in
basically efficient way with these
oughta morphisms that we don't really
know yet why they are useful but before
we now come to the equation what we need
to someone settle with is how do we
could actually commit to our rector s
that we're interested in and as Adam I
said there's basically two ways how to
to to natural ways how to do this or
either you can use directly the
coefficients of the polynomials we
commit to to encode the coefficients of
s or you can encode the coefficients of
the secret vector in in in the energy
basis and in previous protocols always
the problem was that one of these
encoding is good for one thing and the
other is good for another thing so in
particular encoding secret coefficients
in basically in the coefficient basis is
very good for this linear part of our
equation that we need to prove and yeah
especially if the equation we look at is
actually an equation overall ring
because then as we have seen this is
completely trivial with the commitment
scheme we are using it and for practical
purposes purposes would probably be even
less because it would always work with
ring based underlying schemes that we
want to prove things about it but in
this reputation in this representation
we don't really know how to prove
shortness really efficiently and as
vadim has explained this can be done
efficiently if we encode in the entity
basis but then the linear proof gets
gets difficult
so since
the range prove some what seems to be
more difficult what we do is we decides
to use the entity basis to commit to the
coefficients and then we have to say how
we can actually do an efficient linear
proof in in these places okay so now
first for the range proof this we have
also seen before so basically we're ange
proofs are always based on the
observation that something is in minus 1
0 1 if and only if it is the solution to
this equation s times 1 minus s times 1
plus s and now if our commitments are
really such that the entity coefficients
of our polynomials are the secret
ternary coefficients that we're looking
at then multiplying em as especially
polynomials with 1 minus n m + 1 + m
gifts this company is basically all
these interesting products in all the
entities law so we get this pointless
product also after the S vector with the
1 which is basically 1 minus the vector
and then the 1 which is always once plus
the vector and if we're able to prove
that this is 0 and then we have actually
proven that all the coefficients
generate so this is why we want to use
this entity representation and it also
shows why we want to do in product so
but I'm not extracting from here is that
we need to be able to prove products and
they can be polynomial products because
yeah yeah basically a polynomial
products show what we're interested in
in the entity representation so now
there's kind of a general principle of
how to do such product proofs and yeah
the general thing that you always kind
of have is that somehow the the verifier
and the simplest case of course is the
proof of just senses the verify needs to
have some mask opening off of the things
you want to that you want to multiply so
in our case mask openings
of these two polynomials and one and two
that we want to multiply and then now is
basically the same letters y as before
for masking terms that these are
different masking polynomials and in the
opening proof I just don't want to
introduce new notational so if we do
this if the proven sends to mask
openings of m1 and m2 with some
challenge polynomial C then the verifier
can just multiply these two mask
openings and then it gets a new mask
opening of the product so more precisely
this means that if you just multiply F 1
and F 2 then we get some quadratic
polynomial in C where the constant
coefficient is just the product of the
two maskings and we have some linear
term which consists of kind of two cross
terms of Y one times M 2 and Y 2 times M
1 and then in the in the leading term so
the one which is quadratic and in C
where there's actually the product we're
interested in and this can be turned
into proof of our product relation by
letting the the prover commit to these
two boring terms which are in the linear
and constant part so let's call these
polynomials just G 0 and G 1 so the
proof of commits to these two
polynomials and then gives a proof that
this product of these two mask openings
is equal to G 0 plus G 1 C plus MC C
squared so yeah so you has a commitment
to M 3 you can just multiply this by C
squared and then multiply is commitment
of G 1 by C and at all of this 0 and
prove that this is equal to F 1 F 2
which he has and if one does this then
this proves that m1 times m2 is equal to
M 3 but only with zombies around 2 over
Q in this case and the reason is that
although our challenge polynomial now
can be completely uniform and our ring
it is
basically the case that in each entity
coefficient the prover can cheeps
by hoping for C which makes this
quadratic equation true although m1
times m2 is not m3 in this entity
coefficient so basically if if m1 times
m2 is not equal to M 3 in one of the
entity coefficients you can still set up
the proof so that for two challenges
which make this pathetic equation true
or two challenges which have two values
in this entity coefficient you still
gets basically achieve yeah get some
accepting proof so this is why they say
some 0 to abiquiu other then this honest
error there's two more problems with
this approach and they are even more
severe so the first is sending these
mask openings fi is really expensive
because they are basically uniform
polynomials that have to be sent and in
order to yeah prove that these are
actually really masking off of the
messages you also need to then commit to
the masking terms and prove that
otherwise the prover could just send
some some arbitrary polynomials which
don't have anything to do with the ends
and yeah this of course wouldn't make
sense and now I said this protocol only
has some ways to overkill so you need to
repeal it a couple of times and then you
cannot basically use the same masking in
terms Y to mask and with different
challenges other devices would break
their knowledge so if you repeat you
would need additional commitments to Y
and so there there's a huge
amplification of things that you need to
send in order to use this approach so
what we are now doing differently is
that from our opening proof we have this
very nice
basically formulas for the proven
replies into commitments so we do know
that that these that J they are
precisely of this form YJ plus Sigma J C
times in all exacting
so basically for all sees that the
trooper replies and gets an accepting
transcript the set JS of this form and
the commitments also have their this
equation which is given there so if I
know this I can compute the following
terms so I can just take this commitment
vector P I so for the highest method
message multiplied with CJ and subtract
Sigma J of C times TI and if I plug in
now the expressions that I know in the
extraction then I see that in both of
these terms there's there's there's one
equal term which which cancels and
namely this and so in this scalar
product there's one term which is
essentially B times C R and this also
appears in the other trial because the
commitment contains the speed times and
if I multiply by something which is
essentially C then I also get this P
times C times R so this term cancels out
and what remains in the scalar product
is just this three times y term and from
the commitment what remains is just
message times our challenge and if you
look at this now then we see this is
really nothing else then mask opening of
our message so what this means is
there's really no needs to send these
these mask openings we can just let the
verifier compute them itself and then we
save a lot on on communication and
committing to to masking polynomials and
so on so yeah this doesn't have
communication cost and basically the the
well formless of the of the mask
openings is follows by construction and
then the proof is kind of finished by
the same verification equation that one
that basically I explained before but
now we have these four repetitions of
all our protocol with these four
rotations of the challenges and for each
of them we have a mask opening so we
kind of have four
quadratic equations that we can compute
so
yeah so basically for each message we
have four masks openings for all the
four rotations of the challenge we can
multiply two of them then subtract the
corresponding mask opening of the third
message also be the same with the same
challenge and then prove that this is
equal to two garbage terms yeah and yeah
and this yeah okay I hope this is clear
so if we would do this we wouldn't need
to basically for all of these four
repetitions we wouldn't need to commit
to two damage terms so we have four J's
and in this equation there's basically
two G's for every J son total we would
have ate garbage to us and now basically
we see the first instance of why our
automatisms are useful because if we
look at these mask openings from a
slightly different point of view and
apply Sigma minus J to the basically to
the opening of the message with a chase
automorphism then what we get is mask
opening with it just basically the pair
challenge C but with the rotated message
it's just of our or morphisms work we
can linear combine or these mask
openings and then we get some trig attic
polynomial where in the leading
coefficient we actually have a linear
combination of all the rotations of our
message I don't know if this was too
fast
yeah so maybe maybe just say the last
sentence again so by yeah what we are
able to compute is basically some
quadratic equation as before where in
the leading coefficient we now have a
linear combination of the rotation of
the the basic of the relation we are
interested in and this is very useful
because if we now analyze the cheating
probability of the proof
then we see this if we prove that this
is 0 then this already proves really the
fool relation with negligible asanas are
the reason is the following so if we
assume that the relation is not true so
suppose a 1 & 2 is not equal to M 3 then
I mean without loss of generality this
means it is not M 1 times in to minus M
3 is not 0 module of one of these linear
factors but then in this linear
combination that I had on the previous
slide I
I basically rotate this nonzero term to
all the the other entity coefficients
and multiplied with a the completely
uniform factor which comes from the
verifier yeah
so this also j there are challenges from
the verifier so this means that in this
linear combination I get something which
is completely uniform in our rank for
ring although we only basically assumed
that this may be may be may be nonzero
in only one affair entity coefficient so
basically this nonzero thing gets gives
M gets spread out in all the the four
factors which be lie low below below one
of their degrees for playoffs and the
proof I can only treat in at most three
of them because otherwise his challenge
difference would be would be zero in the
in the in the full rank for separating
and therefore this this really proves
basically the relation be interested in
with a negligible service unless 2 to
the minus 1 n 28 okay so now yeah to
breakfast huh so what we have seen is
the base yeah these repetitions of the
opening proof with what morphic
challenges or images of the challenge
and or morphisms allows us to give
getter and an opening proof which isn't
really any any any
repetition or some basic protocol
anymore because we still only have two
garbage terms so one can even do it with
only one garbage turn that we need to
commit okay so this kind of finishes
product truth Shh are there any
questions
you
okay so yeah it's much I can continue
seven
well we can also maybe to some very good
oh no thank you 20 minutes left so just
go okay so now I hope I have kind of
explained how our product roof works and
what remains since that we need to be
able to prove linear equations over our
entity representation and yeah so recall
that we committed two vectors in the
entity basis and we want to prove linear
relations in all of these entity
coefficients and there I think the key
observation we need is as we as I've
said before so the polynomial product is
is compliment bias in the entity basis
and then you need a second observation
and this is the constant polynomial
coefficient is actually the sum over the
entity coefficients and yeah this is
something which is easily seen if one
looks at how the energy algorithm works
in this case the universe entity I
wouldn't so this means together these
two things give us a scalar product
because we can multiply and then we get
products of our basis in the individual
components and then if we look at the
constant coefficient we get the sum of
all of these so to make this a bit more
precise I assume that we have our
message polynomial M with entity is the
secret vector we we're interested in and
then we have some other polynomial a
which in the entity has some some vector
a and if you now take the product of
these polynomials a and M over the ring
and look what this means in the entity
then of course this is just the
component vice product so we multiply a
1 by s 1 and a 2 by s 2 and so on and
then if we look at what this means for
the constant coefficient of the of the
polynomial am so then the map we have to
apply it's basically the inverse entity
and then the math which gives us the
constant coefficient and because
this is just the sum over all the entity
coefficients we see that this is the sum
over these products and why si so this
is nothing else and then the scalar
product of H and s so with this
observation we basically have a tool to
prove scalar products and this is all we
need because as soon as we can prove
scalar products and what we can do is we
prove that yeah a is minus u times some
challenge vector gamma is 0 s is a
scalar product and yeah because this
proves that a is equals to you with
Samus over 1 over Q so I hope this is
clear I mean if is is U then a is minus
U is 0 so the scalar product this is
trivially trivially 0 for all challenges
and otherwise we have some nonzero
polynomial which we take a scalar
product with some random uniformly
random challenge vector so this will be
just some uniformly random element in in
DQ and in particular 0 only with
probability 1 over Q ok so in order to
implement this plan what we need is
basically for our commitment scheme is
that if we have a commitment which is
some are computed in such a way that we
know that the constant coefficient is
some scalar product that we're
interested in then we need to prove
something about this constant
coefficient in our case we need to be
able to prove that the constant
coefficient is 0 so yeah more precisely
we have this polynomial anguish in the
in GTE has this vector s we multiply
this by the polynomial which is 88 years
of the transpose of H I'm Sam's gamma in
the entity and then we subtract nu times
gamma a scalar product and as I
explained before what we get is a
commitment to a polynomial with constant
coefficient is the scalar products and
we need to be able that the constant
proofs we need to be aimed at a constant
coefficient is 0 and this works in the
following way
so what we let the prover do is we let
them commit
to some let's college must in polynomial
G before he sees the challenge Gama so
he commits to some polynomial G which is
zero in the constant coefficient and
then after years seen Gama
the prover can send g plus s and this is
useful because if our relation is not
true
then we know that the constant
coefficient of F's F 0 is some some
uniformly random element and then this
sum plus and something G which is
independent of camera because she was
basically committed to before the prover
saw gamma then also in this son the
constant coefficient will just be random
and otherwise if if if 0 really is 0
then F plus G will also have constant
coefficient 0 because we just in the
constant term will just add two zeros so
this is how this works the the prover
commits to G and then since G Plus F
after seeing gamma and the verifier
checks that this G Plus F is is
correctly computed and at the constant
coefficient is zero now again we need to
sum up boost soundness because as I have
explained proving one scalar product
only gives us some one of a Q so we need
to prove basically four scalar products
which all have random yeah independently
random challenges and then if all of
them are zero then we really have proven
our linear relation with negligible
sarvasah so how do we do this so let's
assume we have four polynomials s where
the constant coefficient always is such
a scalar product with some independent
challenge then what we kind of want to
do is we we want to add them together in
kind of a shifted way so that we get a
polynomial which has four interesting
coefficients in the sense and we do this
by first mapping these
down to the subframe we're basically by
construction every fourth coefficient is
zero but this works by applying the
trace map and it turns out that this
trace map is just given by the sum of
the automatisms we have so this is
really nice because this is something we
can compute and in particular TF now
lies in this suffering so by
construction every fourth coefficient
only every fourth coefficient is nonzero
and and the constant coefficient still
is the scalar product we're interested
in because it's traced my kind of
preserves the constant coefficient of
the scaling so it just gets a constant
coefficient from before but times four
so now if we define this following you
polynomial F which we just compulsive
this trace of our F I but always shifted
by one so we add rotations of F and
always multiply by X to the I then we
get some polynomial where the constant
coefficient is yeah the content
coefficient of F zero so this is some
interesting scalar product there is no
part from the other basically traces or
images under the trace of the other
polynomials because if you rotate them
and the constant coefficient will be
zero by construction and then in the
second coefficient we get a second
scalar product and so on so what we just
need to prove is that first four
coefficients of our polynomial zero and
I hope it is kind of clear how we can do
this with the approach before so this
masking polynomial G that we had is now
just polynomial which is for zero
coefficient in the beginning
okay so this is basically all I wanted
to explain
now are there any questions
you
thank you for a great talk shall we
thank the speaker sorry doc yet do you
still see me and I don't see myself okay
you see okay but deem you are muted I
think and yeah I wasn't saying anything
interesting okay all right thank you so
I think this ends the first day is that
correct yeah and we'll see each other
tomorrow at 8:30